my cousin Tanner sign whatever cause
whatever the problem when you're trying
to work with now in identities or
equations is that they don't mix right
like if you think back to your algebra
days right and you're like collecting
like terms these are unlike terms if you
can't actually get them to interact with
each other unless first you've been
doing that in your actual identities you
turn crossbred into science where 1
minus 1 over 1 so you've got to do some
adjustment right now this problem or
their beam of light is very similar to
the problem of fractions now these
fractions they can't talk to each other
either they are unlike terms they can't
interact unless so what will we convert
them into what we want is a common
denominator right so what's the common
denominator that I would choose here I
would choose a cloth so this is 3 over
12 and this is 2 over 12 and now they
can talk you can get the itself ok so
you happy with that
now here's important things tumors right
number 112 right that's not unique there
are plenty of other common denominators
that I could have chosen for instance
you know we're not here seven first
loads to do this the classic where they
get a common denominator is you multiply
right so the first thing that they might
do is say oh well twenty-fourths so this
would become 24th or 24th and you would
end up at the same answer which is yeah
okay so common denominators are not
unique but some are better than others
right does that make sense
now the question I posed to you this is
this I'm trying to segue in rather give
you this concept and just be sort of
here just do this why I don't know
because I said so right what if we could
get a common denominator just like we
have a fraction what if we could get a
common denominator
functions one kind of you know language
that they can all speak and then you
could just shove them all together
simplify out and it all be happy okay I
don't know about you I poses personal
question to myself and what I thought
about what common denominator could I
get for psychos and tan the first
indicates in my head is sign because
sign is kind of like the basic function
it's where cosine gets its name from it
just means complements sine and tan as
you know it's just a combination of the
other two right so let's just imagine
for a second and I want you to write
this with me right
let's let's try and get sine of X the
common denominator
how would it work how could we get cos
and ten in terms of sines right well
just to make things easier for us let's
let sine X be something short on okay
let's let it be yes just as short here
okay now let's tackle cosine first
because they are very close together
sorry cosine are most easily related
through the Pythagorean relationship
right so it's go ahead plus cos squared
is one we get that from the unit circle
right so if sine squared plus cos
squared is equal to one right and I want
to get cos in terms of science right
I'll kick that side squared over the
other side okay
in fact I don't even really need to
write sine scale I can just write this
weird and then if I want cause on its
iron I take the square root right well
of course you only careful right when
you take square roots of things you
gotta realize there's two solutions to a
quadratic related so I'm gonna get this
let's pause on that for a minute let it
let it sit what about 10 well if I heard
side and an air cause tans pretty easy
tan is gonna be the ratio between those
right so it's gonna be sine or cosine so
that plus or minus let's just let it
hang out on the top because that's a one
natural place to put it plus or minus s
on that okay
so this is one way to approach the
problem of getting a common denominator
between all of them then I if I see
signs and causes and tangent and
identity
I just turn them all into s's right but
the problem is this pesky plus or minus
okay because you're like I don't know
which one it's going to be which one
it's going to be will depend on the
value of X so if X is within a certain
range it'll be positive and if it's
within another range should say domain
it'll be negative now that's a report
that means every time you use this
method you've got to do cases that's a
pain not only the time consumed it's
also a very error-prone way to do things
okay so signs not a good twist for
coming divided up you can probably
imagine if we chose cosine instead you
get the same problem right it's just a
little bit of rearranging it seizes to
the aesir's okay so what's a better
common denominator well after a lot of
play around okay it turns out that 10 of
X on to she turns out to be a really
really good choice that you like her
really when I was taught this they call
this T and so the whole concept under
this is quality results when I was 12
Ennis and in most textbooks they just
start off like this they say let T equal
10 excellent - and then they start to
produce all this all these formulas
because of it and they're like well why
I just like trig is hard enough already
why are you introducing weird arbitrary
rules in which they don't make things
any easier for me and seriously what
could be here's why it's because well
the other alternatives suck they've done
the work for you and already worked out
this is the best one okay so even though
textbooks may seem abrupt all right
which is confusing they're actually
timed in your favor
they spare you the process of working
out that all of these options
I'll show you see no no common
denominator is without faults so this
way of doing it or cosine or half angle
results like we're using here for
santoku so they have got this plus or
minus problem this has only problem too
but as you discover it's a pretty simple
problem to get rid of okay probably
actually do with that next week we'll
see if we get